you're watching swype coming up on the
show this week the latest apps and
gadgets that can help you stay safe on
the streets we test out one bit of tech
employers are using to protect their
staff and the world's biggest football
game is back but it's FIFA 16 a winner
or a footy flop we've all been there
you're in an area you don't know too
well you'll by yourself and you're
starting to feel a little bit vulnerable
it's enough to put anyone on edge but
what apps and gadgets are there to help
us feel and stay safe Angela's been
taking a look Rebecca pic is hoping her
invention will help keep girls and women
safe from sexual assaults the 22 year
old came up with the idea for a personal
safety device after a fellow student was
attacked outside her flat in Glasgow the
personal Guardian is a lightweight
discreet personal attack alone working
alarm when you activate it it will
connect via your smartphone to a central
monitoring station who listen in and
assess the situation they send all that
information to the police along with
your GPS location who respond as a high
priority response there are tens of
thousands of violent sexual assaults
each year and victims may not be able to
get to their device or phone in a
struggle taking inspiration from
wearable technology Rebecca went with a
design that lets you click the alarm on
to a bra strap or belt making it more
discreet as well as devices
incorporating GPS tracking there's also
a wide variety of personal safety apps
being developed to help watch your back
some alert you if you're entering a high
crime area and others like this watch
over me up let you share your journey
with selected friends or family in real
time so they can see when you're home
safely
this is the companion app it also lets
you choose friends to accompany you on
your way home by sending them a message
the apple soda tech spikes in your
heartbeat and can sound an alarm or send
a message to a police station another
the react mobile safety app has a share
your location feature and an SOS button
which sends friends and emergency text
which can optionally be posted to social
media sites but personal security
experts say apps shouldn't be completely
relied on if you're under duress or
you're experiencing fear or high stress
you have physiological responses to that
and what happens when your heart rate
goes up your cognitive processing drops
and your fine motor movements the
dexterity and your fingers isn't
available to you if you were very scared
you wouldn't be able to actually
function any of those functionality keys
so whilst technology can't be relied on
to get you home safely a bit of extra
reassurance may help along the way
Angela Barnes Sky News right well have
got a bike now because it's tower I
tested out one of these personal
protection out some with me is John
Cameron and the stay safe app and this
is aimed at business owners absolutely
there's about six million lone workers
in the UK all of their employers have a
duty of care to look after those
employees when there aren't working
alone so you track you track star that's
correct so I'm gonna pretend to be one
of your employees and I'm gonna go run
an errand now on my bike maybe five
minute errand yeah so how can we set up
my session very simple we just start a
session we say we're gonna be out for
perhaps ten minutes it immediately zooms
in and finds you you've got the option
to enter some notes or you can just
start the session oh it's counting down
I'm on the clock now right and as soon
as you do that your employer can now
track you on the map right I guess
see you later
right I'm gonna pull over we can see
whether this app really knows that I am
now I'm really not too sure I'm not too
familiar with this area so I I'm gonna
pretend I'm lost let's see what this app
does so I guess it's panic are you sure
let's pack now this should be telling
Don but I need some help hi there Gemma
see you just press the panic button is
everything ok ok right we'll be around
to pick you up in a couple of minutes
Tony found me I general to rescue me All
Right see where I was the whole high the
whole time we tracked you when you panic
now what if I was really far away though
depends on what your employer wants to
do they can either dispatch a colleague
to look for you or the emergency
services what if I don't want to meet
Raph you're only track when you as the
employee want to be tracked ah good
tonight now before our games review with
Holly here's a roundup of some of this
week's tech news google unveiled its
latest nexus smartphones this week as it
looks to take on the Apple 6s and 6 plus
the company says the Nexus 6p carries
its best-ever camera it can take photos
at 30 frames a second both of the new
handsets are cheaper than the latest
iPhone offerings from Apple while we're
talking Apple a record 30 million iphone
6s and 6s plus phones were bought on the
first three days they went on sale last
week Apple boss Tim Cook described it as
phenomenal the new success has a better
camera faster processor and a
pressure-sensitive screen for the first
time and you know when you're talking to
a friend hands-free and then the
conversation gets drowned out by noises
around you well novo can automatically
adjust the volume in your headphones
according to the sounds around you so
it's always at the same level adaptive
sound technologies has been raising
money through crowdfunding on IndieGoGo
to get the device to market now the
world's biggest football game is back
but is it a title challenger here's
Holly with our games review
this year FIFA 16 is slightly slower
though although you compare it next you
know next to a 50-50 you probably won't
notice the difference there are a couple
of changes on the pitch and they're
quite slight though and they're also
kind of double edged so the goalies have
been fixed there are a lot better this
time but sometimes they can be a little
too good and make things quite difficult
for you
there's also the addition of women's
international team which is a brilliant
thing there's a whole new area of
football that they're discovering and
I'll be a lot more inclusive and bring
people in and so overall there are a
couple of slight differences not that
much has changed however the official
licenses and the the game modes like
ultimate team which are always popular
will keep people satisfied you know what
sucks about dying the crash soma is
developed by frictional games the
developers of a classic horror game
amnesia this game is less outwardly
horror there aren't any kind of them
cheap jump scares the horror is really
found in the environment the kind of
atmosphere and the idea of kind of
loneliness and isolation it's a very
clever game a story it's very story
driven and it kind of deals with some
very interesting themes now it does
there's not a lot of signposting there's
no map it doesn't really tell you where
to go so that kind of adds to the horror
a bit you get a little bit lost but
sometimes when you're kind of wandering
around aimlessly looking what to do it
can get a little bit frustrating however
if you're a fan of horror or sci-fi
there will be a lot in this game that
will keep you happy
animalcrossing happy home designer has
all the charm that's found in the rest
of the series however it's a bit
different instead of this time just
being part of a town you are actually an
employee of Tom Nook at a design you
design people's homes and their to
whatever they want no there's no way of
really failing this game you know you
can't complete the homes without the
things that clients have given you but
you know no matter what you do they'll
always love it so although that gives
you a lot of creative freedom it doesn't
really give you much of a motivation to
improve but the real join this game is
found in designing aspects of the town
so you design a hospital or school
things like that and then the villagers
use it and that's very satisfying so for
fans of the series they'll you know
they'll be a lot in it for them there's
a lot of recurring characters which is
good but it could perhaps do with a bit
more of Animal Crossing really maybe can
event having your own home to design
would be good however it is incredibly
fun game and I think a lot of people are
like it
well that's it for this week but take a
look at Sky News on mobile and iPad for
some bonus features from this week's
episode including some advice from a
personal safety expert and some more
gadgets and apps to keep you safe see
you next time bye bye